Hi, my name is Will Davis and Iwork with MaaS360, an IBM product.
Today we're going to begin talking about
Unified Endpoint Management, or UEM.
This is going to be a first part in a multi-part
series. So definitely hit that "Like" button and
get ready to subscribe to see more contentabout UEM.
UEM is going to be the next step in the MDM chain.
What's MDM? MDM is going tobe your Mobile Device Management.
This is going to give you the ability to manage all of your iOS
devices and your Android devices in one place.
Once you begin to have your iOS and Androiddevices enrolled and connected to an MDM
or UEM, you're probably going to want tobegin to deploy applications, documents,
email settings, containerized, etc., into thosedevices.
And that is going to be your enterprise mobility management part of the equationhere.
But lastly, you notice that we'reonly talking about iOS and Android so far whenwe're talking about MDM.
In your environment, you probably have more than just iOS andAndroid.
So, we're going to begin to mix in Windows and MacOS.
These are the last twopieces of our equation.
So, we're going to go ahead and add up all the pieces and we're
going to finish with our UEM here at the top.
Up till now, most of the industry has worked withWindows and MacOS kind of in their own littlebubble,
needing to be on the domain to getconnected in and really needing to have everything in one place to take care of it all.
With theshift into UEM from separate portals,
you get one unified location to manage everything together.
Soyou no longer have to worry about coming into the office with all these Windows and MacOS devices
and plugging them in to get them joined up.
You can do it all over the air with UEM.
On top ofjust going through and enrolling all the devices,
you're going to get all the benefits of an EMMfor iOS and Android,
and you get to extend it into your Windows and MacOS world.
You'regoing to be able to start doing BYOD devices,
corporate owned devices as well, and with those beBYOD devices,
you don't have to worry about that personally identifiable informationgetting out into your corporate side,
or any of your corporate information getting
into your personal side of those devices.
The UEM is going to offer you options forautomated enrollment programs,
so that, turn on the device, it boots right up, and connects right intothe UEM.
So, you're not sitting there plugging in a lot of information
and your end users don'thave to do a lot of extra work on their own.
Once you go through the enrollment process,
you'regoing to then be able to deploy restrictions down to the devices.
Are you worried aboutcameras being used in an inappropriate place?
Go ahead, turn that off.
You'reworried about password security?
Passwords can be enforced everywhere as well.
So, on top of restrictions, you're also going to get compliance statuses.
Your compliance statusis going to then refer back into your UEM portal,
and let you know if they're doing anythinginappropriate that they shouldn't be doing.
Lastly, you're going to be able to integrateyour UEM directly with your already establishedenvironments.
All the hard work you already doin Active Directory,
automatically integrated with a couple easy steps.
Get the benefits ofit there as well.
Your email, either in the cloud or on-prem, integrated as well.
And allof those GPO rules you've already established for your Windows or MacOS machines
can be importedin and used as well inside of one place.
And lastly, deploying software: you'reused to plugging in flash drives
or installing over file shares.
Now youcan deploy them over the air. Easy. No extra work needed.
So, going over allthis so far, this is just an early, simple, easy look at unified endpoint management andhow it's going to affect you.
So, definitely hit that "Like" button, get subscribed, and get
ready for future content in this series.